[Music]
country music's favorite icon dolly
parton was born january 19
1946 in the smoky mountains of tennessee
her family was poor really poor
the no heat no electricity no indoor
plumbing no running water kind of
poor the only somewhat modern thing they
had was a battery-powered radio
so young dolly fell in love with the
music she heard writing songs when she
was just a toddler and getting her first
guitar when she was eight
when she was 15 she signed on as a staff
songwriter for a publishing company
then landed a deal with mercury records
where she recorded a single
which flopped so she went home to finish
high school
the first in her family of 12 children
to graduate
the day after she graduated she took a
bus right back to nashville
dolly wasn't giving up so easily to
support herself she worked several jobs
she was a receptionist at a neon sign
company a waitress
and a singer on a local early morning tv
program
in the 1960s dolly was still building up
the music part of her resume
she became a staff writer at combine
music earning 50 dollars a week
but her big break was the porter wagner
show where dolly parton overshadowed the
namesake host
and developed her own little fan base
she achieved 10 solo number one hits
the namesake host had none but despite
her stardom she was still making the
same union pay as the band members
200 to 350 per concert
after many years working with porter
wagner she left the show
starting her career as a solo artist she
wrote a song you probably heard of
which was inspired by her departure from
[Music]
wagner
that song ended up being one of her
biggest hits it was re-recorded by
several artists
including whitney houston in 1992 whose
rendition went on to earn dolly 10
million dollars that year alone in
royalties
when she left the show she wisely formed
her own publishing company
and to this day maintains ownership of
all her songs
in the next few years as a solo artist
her concert booking fees
increased fivefold she was earning one
hundred thousand dollars a year
almost double her show salary throughout
the next few decades
pardon accomplished what most would do
in a lifetime
as she evolved from country music writer
and singer to full-on pop star
then dabbled in bluegrass her extensive
list of credits include
acting writing oh and she happens to be
godmother to miley cyrus
outside of the music she's capitalized
on her country charm
opening dollywood in 1986 and dollywood
splash country in 2001
followed by dollywood's dream more
resort and spa
in 2015. she created imagination library
an organization that has donated more
than 150 million free books to children
she also more recently made headlines
when it was revealed her one million
dollar donation to covet research
helped fund the moderna vaccine crazy to
think that the same little girl who
listened to an old radio in a one-room
house
would end up one of the most prolific
singer-songwriters in the world
paving the way for so many others to
follow in her diamond high-heeled
footsteps
[Music]
you